ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะผู้หญิงคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันนี้มันพุธนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะเดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะปีพตเท่าไหร่คะดีผช
2556  5  5 ค่ะบางที่พูดปีมีอะไรได้ไหมๆ
นะ 5 ปีพตเท่าไหร่ปีอะไรโอเคนะคะค่ะปีคน
ศ.เท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะครูหญิงวันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันนี้
วันพุธตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
18:00 นค่ะครูเอ๋
18:00 นโง่ต้องมีพระจันทร์ได้ไหม
พระจันทร์มืดใช่ไหม 18:00 นกำลังจะ
มือมืดไหมขึ้นไหมมืดๆเลยค่ะ
มืดนะคะอ่ะ
โอเคเอกเก็บแบบ
ผู้หญิงคะวันนี้มีนักเรียนกี่คนคะ
วันนี้มีนักเรียนถ้ามีทั้งหมด 1  2  3  4
5  6  7  8  9
995 นักเรียน 9 คน
เด่นดีใจนักเรียนมานะคะมามาๆดีใจๆมาเยอะๆ
นะฮะหนึ่ง
เลยคะ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋มี
คำถามไหมคะ
มีคำถามแต่ว่าถามครูหญิงอ๋อ
โอเคค่ะพี่เอ๋จะถามครูหญิงนะคะอ่ะการครู
เอ๋วันนี้ขอ Share  screen
มีได้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเห็นไหม
เห็นค่ะครูเอกกับเหมาอะไรคะครูเอ๋อะ
นาฬิกา
อามานี่นาฬิกาเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋จะทำคู่หญิงตัว
ใหญ่ๆก่อนนะคะป่าซื้อ
โอเค
กูเอ็ด
ทำผู้หญิงใหญ่ๆว่ะ
เพราะว่า Share  screen
ผู้หญิงตัวเล็กๆตอนนี้กูเอกต้องทำผู้หญิง
ตัวใหญ่ๆก่อน
นะสักครู่นะคะได้ค่ะอะที่วีดีโอคุยอีกคู๋
นะคะจะต้องให้ผู้หญิงใหญ่ๆอ้าวโอเค
ผู้หญิงคะอันนี้
อันนี้แหละเราเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะ
นาฬิกาค่ะนาฬิกาจะมีเข็มนะคะมีเข็มทั้ง
หมดกี่เข็มคะอ่ะโอ้นี่เข็มทั้งหมด 3 เข็ม
ค่ะ 3 เข็มนะคะเข็มที่หนึ่งอ้ะเข็มสั้น
ยาวหรือยาวที่สุด
เข็มที่ 1 เข็มสั้นค่ะเข็มสั้นนะคะเข็ม
สั้นอ่ะกู a ให้เป็นตอนนี้ 6 โมงใช่ไหมคะ
อ่ะใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวนะคะ
กูเองจะเขียนได้ไหมได้ค่ะ
เกมที่ 1 เป็นเข็มสั้น
โอเคไหมโอเค
เข็มสั้นเข็มใหญ่ๆเนาะถ่ายค่ะเข็มสั้น
แล้วก็จะอีก
เข็มที่ 2 เข็มอะไรคะเข็มที่ 2 เข็มยาว
มั้ยเขียนยาวเข็มยาวหากเข็มยาวอ่ะคู๋ให้
เข็มยาวไปตัวเลข
12 ราคะ
แล้วก็คิดยาวไปใช่ไหม
ยาวไปขอโทษค่ะ
นิดหน่อย
ตื่น
โอเคไหมอ่าเกมส์ที่สองเข็มยาวเข็มที่ 3
เนี่ยจะยาวที่สุดแต่เราไม่พูดเข็มยาวที่
สุดพูดเข็มอะไรคะพูดเข็มวินาทีค่ะเข็ม
วินาทีสีอะไรนะคะสีแดงไหมคะครูอะไรค่ะ
โอเค
เข็มวินาทีสีแดงถ้าอยู่ที่เดียวกันโอเค
อุ้ย
คู๋ทำอะไร
อ่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋วาดเข็มยาวใหม่แล้วก็ว่า
มีเข็มวินาที
เข็มวินาทียาวที่สุดยาวที่สุดนะครับ
ผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋วาดนะแล้วคุยหญิงพูด
นะคะเพราะว่าเวลากี่โมงนะคะได้วันนี้
18:00 นใช่ไหมคะ
18:00 น
18:00 นนี่ 6 โมงเย็นครูเอ๋เอา 6 โมง
เย็นก่อนก็ได้ค่ะตอนนี้ 6 โมงเย็นนะคะอ่า
คุยลบนะ
ลบๆนี่
18:00 น
สักครู่นะคะได้ค่ะ
รอได้ค่ะรอได้นะคะผู้ต้องลบพี่
แท็ปเข็มสั้นมาเข็มสั้นนะคะค่ะ
เข็มสั้นมาที่
เลข 7 เลข 7 กี่โมงคะผู้หญิง
อันนี้ 18:00 นใช่ไหมค่ะ 18:00 นนะฮะเข็ม
สั้นไปเลข 7 พูดว่าอะไรคะ
19:00 นค่ะ 1 ทุ่มนะคะ
แต่คุยลบแต่ 7:00 น
แล้วถ้าเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 8
กี่โมงคะ
20:00 นค่ะ 20:00 นราคา
ถ้าเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 9 กี่มีโครงคะ
3 ทุ่มค่ะ 9:00 นเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 10
กี่โมงคะ
10:00 นค่ะ 10:00 นเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 11
11:00 นค่ะคาร์ทูม
เข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 12 กี่โมงคะเที่ยงคืน
ค่ะเที่ยงคืนเข็มสั้นไปเล็ก 1 กี่โมงคะตี
หนึ่งค่ะปีหนึ่งนะคะ
เข็มสั้นไปเลข 2 กี่โมงคะปี 2 ค่ะอันนี้
เป็น
ปีหนึ่งนี่ 1:00 นอ่ะ
แต่
01:00 นนะคะอ๋ออันนี้เข็มสั้นไปเลข 2 ก็
ตีสองนะคะตี 2
เข็มสั้นไปเลข 3 กี่โมงคะ
ตี 3 ค่ะปีสามนะคะ
เข็มสั้นไปที่เล็ก 4
กี่โมงคะ
ตี 4 ค่ะปี 4
เข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 5 กี่โมงคะ
05:30 น 05:00 นเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 6 กี่
โมงคะ
6 โมงเช้าค่ะ
6:00 นอันนี้
เป็นเช้าแล้วเนาะลูกชายค่ะตื่นนอนขอราคา
อะคูเวตลบก่อนนะคะ - ๆ - วันนี้
เป็นอะไรละ a ตอนเช้าเช้าค่ะ
ตอนเช้านะคะ
18:00  -
06:00 นนะคะ 06:00 น - ๆ Love
ค่าเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 7 ราคะผู้หญิงค่ะ
7:00 นค่ะเจ็ดโมงเช้าวันนี้มีพระอาทิตย์
แล้วเนาะค่ะ
พระอาทิตย์ร้อนนะคะเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 8
ราคะ
8:00 นค่ะมีเช้าอยู่ใช่ไหมคะตัวเองเช้า
8:00 น 8:00 นนี้นะคะเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 9
ค่ะคู่หญิง
9:00 นเช้าไหมคะเช้าโอเคเช้าเนาะ 9 โมง
สาวค่ะเก้าโมงเช้าโอเคค่ะ
เกมสั้นไปที่เลข 10 ค่ะ
10:00 นค่ะ 10:00 นไม่เช้าก็ได้
10:00 นก็ ok  10:00 น Ok  10:00 น Ok
โอเคคะเข็มสั้นไปเลข 11 ราคา
11 โมงค่ะ
11:00 น
เข็มสั้นไปเลข 12
เที่ยงค่ะเที่ยง
เที่ยงคืน 12:00 น
เที่ยงวันโอเคไหมคะครูเอ๋เที่ยงวันโอเคมี
เพียงโอเคนะคะ
เข็มสั้นไปที่เลขหนึ่งค่ะครูหญิง
บ่ายโมงค่ะ
13:00 น
เข็มสั้นไปโทษค่ะ
เค็มสั้นไปที่เลข 2 ราคาวิยาว
เข็มสั้นค่ะบ่าย 2 โมงค่ะบ่าย 14:00 นนะ
คะเข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 3 ราคะ
บ่าย 3 โมงค่ะบ่าย 15:00 นเข็มสั้นไปที่
เลข 4 ราคะ
16:00 นค่ะ
16:00 นน
เข็มสั้นไปที่เลข 5 ราคะ
17:00 นค่ะ 5 โมงเย็นอ่าโอเคเข็มสั้นไป
ที่แรก 6 ราคา
18:00 นค่ะ 18:00 นผังหมดกี่ชั่วโมงคะ
หางหมด 24 ชั่วโมงค่ะ 24 ชั่วโมงนะคะทั้ง
หมด 24 ชั่วโมงราคาเอกขยายตรงนี้หน่อย
ทั้งหมด 24 ชั่วโมง
อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะค่ะอย่างไรขยายแล้วทำไมไม่
ขยาย
รอนิดนึงคุยลบก่อนค่ะ - หน้า - ชายรอได้
ค่ะรอนะคะ
คุณโรคอันนี้ด้วยอ่ะ
โอเคคุยคุยลบหมดเลยดีกว่าขอรบเข็มสั้นถ้า
เข็มยาวเข็มวินาที
ทรายอะคุยลบนะคะอ่านแล้วกูอีกว่าใหม่นะคะ
ได้ค่ะโอเคเอา
เข็ม
วินาทีอยู่เล็กๆ
เล็กๆยาว
สีแดง
วิ่งนาทีถึงวินาทีอ่ะอยู่ที่นี่เข็ม
วินาทีนะคะ
เราก็
คู๋เอาไซส์ใหญ่ขึ้นสีดำเข็มยาวหรือเข็ม
สั้นคะเข็มสั้นกูเอาเข็มสั้นไว้ที่
เลข 7 อา
แล้วก็มี
แต่ก็ยังไม่เจ็บคุย
นี่เข็มสั้นใกล้ๆเลข 7 ค่ะแล้วก็เข็มยาว
อยู่ที่อยู่ที่เลขอะไรคะเลข 10 นะคะกี่
โมงคะครูหญิง
18:50 นนค่ะ
18:00 น 50 น
บ้านที่พูดอีก
10 นาที
เอกสิบนาที
7:00 นได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะ
พูด
18:50 น
พูดอีก 10 นาทีที่ 7:00 นนะคะอุ๊อุ๊ 07:00
นหรือท่าม
กลางวันหรือรางซื้นครูเอ๋กลางวันกลางวัน
กลางวันกลางวันหากกลางวันมหากลางวันมีพระ
อาทิตย์นะกลางวันกลางคืนกลางคืนนี้พระ
จันทร์
พระจันทร์ผู้
การคืน
โอเคครูเอ๋รู้แล้วทำยังไงอ่ะกูเอ๋จะลบ
ก่อนนะคะผู้หญิงได้ค่ะติด - รถ -
ๆๆกูเห็นลบหมดเลยค่ะครูเอ๋
ลบเข็มออกหมดนะค่ะกูเห็นลบที่นี่อบ - ดวง
อาทิตย์
เลยรถนี่
ok นะคะรักครูเอกก็ใส่สีเอาผู้หญิงชอบ
กลางวันหรือกลางคืน
คุณครูหญิงชอบกลางวันค่ะเกาะกลางวันกลาง
วันสีอะไรสีแดง
ปู่ได้ค่ะแดง
สีส้มสีส้มสีส้มอ้าโอเคกลางวันสีส้ม
หากครูเอ๋จะเช็คผู้หญิง
เข็มสีแดงอยู่ที่ 12
a พูดครูหญิงเขียนโอเคมั้ยเฮ้ยได้ค่ะสัก
ครู่นะคะรางวัลนะกลางวัน
ได้ไหม
ผู้หญิงค่ะ aom บอกและผู้หญิงก็บอกคู๋เลข
อะไรก็ได้เอาเทพผู้หญิงเขียนได้นะได้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเขียนเข็มสั้นแล้วก็เข็มยาวนะค่ะ
อ่ะ
อา
โออิ 6 โมงช่างวัน
หกโมงเช้า
6:00 น 6:00 นเข็มสั้นอยู่ที่เลข 6  5
ผู้หญิง
6 โมง 45 นาที
ได้ไหมผู้หญิงได้ไหมค่ะอ่ะโอเค 6 โมง 45
นาทีนิเข็มสั้นอยู่ตรงนี้
เข็มยาวอยู่ที่ไหนคะเข็มยาวอยู่ที่เล่น 9
ผู้หญิงจะเขียนยากนิดหน่อยฮ่าๆๆ ok ลบๆ
ไม่ปิ๊งป่องๆ
ขอให้ผู้หญิงลบไปแล้วเนาะ
โอเค S อีก 5 นาที
7:00 น
เอก 15 นาที
7:00 นไทยขาดอีก 15 นาที
7:00 นผู้หญิงไม่โกรธครูเอ๋นะไม่โกรธ
เข็มสั้นอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะใกล้ๆ 7  5
เกมยาวอยู่ที่เลข 9 ห้อเดิมใช่
6 โมง 45 นาทีได้ค่ะถ้าคิด 6 โมงพูด 6
โมง 45 นาที
ถ้าคิด
กลางวันใช่ไหม 07:00 นก็พูดและอีก
15 นาที
07:00 นขอเหมือนครูเอ๋บอกตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
ค่ะ
15 นาทีถ้าให้ 15 นาทีก็คิด 7 ใช่ไหมคิด
ที่เจ็ดก็พูดอีก 15 นาที
07:00 นถ้าผู้หญิงเอาใหม่ลบๆนี้กูเองไม่
แกล้งแล้ว R
11:00 น
15 นาที
11:15 น
11:00 น 15 นาทีค่ะเข็มสั้นอยู่เลข 11
เข็มยาวอยู่ที่ไหนคะอยู่เลข 3 ค่ะเมื่อ
เข็มยาวอยู่เลข 3 นะคะโอเค
มีผู้หญิง
31 ไม่เอา 11 ละ 12:30 นโห 12:30 นค่ะ
เข็มสั้น
เข็มสั้นประมาณนี้
พี่เพียง
เกมยาวอยู่เลข 6 ค่ะก็เที่ยงครึ่งนะคะ
อย่างผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอา
เที่ยงคืนกู
เที่ยงคืนถึงเที่ยงคืนไม่ใช่ 12:30 น
24:00 นรางคืนกลางคืนเวลาสั้นค่ะกลางคืน
กลางคืน
เที่ยงคืน
หนังสั้นอยู่เลข 12 เข็ม
ยาวเข็มยาวอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่เลข 12 หน้าเข็ม
ยาวก็อยู่เลข 12 นะคะเที่ยงคืนไม่ใช่
เที่ยงครึ่งนะคะกลางคืนนะกลางคืน
โอเคอ่ะเอาเองกลับมากลางวัน
ผู้หญิงคะอ่า
บ่าย
15:00 น
มีนาที
25 นาทีน
3:00 นเข็มสั้นอยู่เลข 3 ค่ะ
25 นาทีนะคะ 25 นะนีเข็มยาวอยู่อยู่อุ่น
อ่ะที่อยู่เลขอะไรคะ
อยู่เลข 5 ค่ะที่เลข 5 นะคะโอเคไหมนัก
เรียนอ่ะนะโอเคนักเรียนเข้าใจนะอ่าเดี๋ยว
คุณเอ๋พูดผู้หญิงดูนักเรียนเขียนเลขอะไร
นะคะถ้าอ่า
หรือว่าผู้หญิงจะพูดคุยเขียนผู้หญิงพูดดี
กว่าครูเขียนได้ๆๆตัวเอกเขียนง้อนักเรียน
คิดนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนคิดเข็มสั้นเลข
อะไรเข็มยาวเลขอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงจะเอากี่
โมงคะเอากลางวันหรือกลางคืนเอากลางคืนไม่
เอากลางวันแล้วการกลางคืนโอเคมีดาวมีลาว
อุ้ย
ขอโทษเมื่อคืนที่ไหนคะ
มีดาว
น้าด่าคือดาวมีพระจันทร์ค่ะกลางคืน
โอเคค่ะผู้หญิงอยากรู้เวลากี่โมง
รู้เหรอคะเวลา
9:00 น 40 น
3 อันนี้เลข 3
21:00 นกลางคืนกลางคืนโอเคๆๆ
21:00 น
อา-นิ-สง
สั้นที่เลข 9 ค่ะ
กี่นาทีคะ
ลาทีค่ะโอเคเข็มถ้าไม่ใช่ที่เลข 9 เข็ม
สั้นอยู่
นิ
เคมสั้นเลยเลยเลข 9 นะคะเข็มยาวอยู่ที่
เลข 10 ค่ะเห้ย 40
PA  O  AI  Q ไม่ดีอ่ะ
อยู่ที่เล็ก 8 ค่ะใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะ
ก็เป็น
9:40 น
หรืออีกใช้อีก
20 นาที
22:00 นนะคะใช่โอเคโอเคตื่นตื่นตื่นตื่น
ๆๆ
โอ้วครูเอ๋คะคุณลชเขียนเวลาให้ครูเอ๋วาด
เข็มสั้นเข็มยาวค่ะเด้อผู้เขียนว่ากี่โมง
คุณแรสบอกคุณแบรดบอกอ่าอ่ากลางคืนนะกลาง
คืนนะกลางคืนคุณแบรดบอกว่า
08:10 นอีค่ะ 20:00 น 20:00 น 20:00 นก็
เลข 8
10 นาทีเหรอคะโอเคสิค่ะ 20:10 นโอเคเข็ม
[เพลง]
โอเคเข็มสั้น
อยู่ตรงนี้อ่า
5 อยู่ที่เลข 8 เลยไปนิดหน่อยแอร์
10  19 อยู่ที่ไหน 10  10 นาทีค่ะนะอะไร
นะสิบเอางา 10 นาทีโอขอโทษค่ะอ่าไม่ใช่
ยี่สิบนาที
ตัวเอง a&t เลข 2 ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
รู้วันนี้ครูเองง่วงนอนใช่มั้ยเนี่ย
6 โมงเองนะคะเกิดคุย
มาใหม่คุณแคทมาใหม่อยากให้ครูเอ๋เขียน
เข็มค่ะเขียนว่าเขียนกี่โมงคะกลางวันหรือ
กลางคืนกลางคืนกลางคืนกี่โมงช้างคุณแคท
คุณแคทอยากกี่โมงคุณแคทบอกว่า
5:00 น 50 น5น
ซีรีย์ 5 เท่าไหร่ 5:00 น
55 น
อาร์อาร์ 5:55 เข็มสั้น
โอเคอ้าใกล้ๆข้าว
5  10  15  20  25 น 30 น 35
45  50 นโอเคค่า 10 คู่หรือยังเข็มยาว
อยู่เลขอะไร
เท่าไหร่ 55 ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ 55  55 เกมยาว
อยู่เลข 11 ค่ะโอ้
เพลงมากค่ะ IQ  IQ
ครูเอครูเอ๋คะอันนี้พูดอีก 5 นาทีฉันหก
โมงเช้าได้ไหมได้ค่ะพูดอีก 5 นาที
6:00 นโอเค
มีใครอยากรู้เวลาอะไรอีกคะ
คุณทาดาชิค่ะสวัสดีค่ะคุณแพรนะชิ
คุนทาดาชิ
คุณทาดาชิพ่อปกลางวันไม่ชอบกลางคืนค่ะ
กลางวันเหรอถ้าคุณทานอาทิไก่ค่ะได้ค่ะ
อุ้ย
กลางวันอ่านควรทาดาชิเขียนบอกว่าเดี๋ยวนะ
กูเห็นรถพระจันทร์ - ดาวก่อนนะคะคุณทาน
อาชีพได้ค่ะ
คุณคุณทาดาชิอยากรู้เวลากี่โมงคะ
คุณถ้ามีการชิอยากรู้เวลา
14:00 น
กี่นาทีบ่าย 2 โมง 35 นาที
35 นาทีกี่วินาที
มี 15 วินาที
ลบอันนี้ก่อนนะ
ซื้อปุ๋ย
อั้ยย่ะไอ้ห่ากูยังมีไอ้ยาด้วยนะ
บ่าย 2 โมง 35 นาที
15 วินาที
บ่าย 14:00 นค่ะออก
14:35 นโอเคเข็มสั้นอยู่ตรงกลาง
ขาด 5 เข็มสั้นรูปใหญ่ๆนะอยู่ตรงกลางเลข 2
กับเลข 3 เลข 2 เอ่อเลข 3  35 นาที
กับเข็มยาวอยู่ตรงไหนตัวเองเห็น 35 แล้ว
อุ้ยเขียนเอาไว้
สามสิบห้านาทีกี่วินาทีนะคะ
15 วินาทีค่ะ 15 วินาที
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะคุณชายตาชิบอกเก่งไหมคะ
โอเค
ไม่เก่งหรอ
แต่ครูเอกคะครู a คะอะไรคะตอนนี้นักเรียน
บอกหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วหรอโอ้โอ้ะ
วันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก 24 ชั่วโมงรู้จัก
นาฬิกานะนาฬิกาคถ้าเข็มสั้นเข็มชั่วโมง
ค่ะเห็นยาวเข็มบอกนาที
เข็มเล็กๆเข็มสีแดงสีแดงค่ะสีแดงอ่ะเข็ม
บอกวินาทีนะคะอ๋อหมดเวลาแล้ว
โอเคโอเคปิดนะคะใส่ค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วครูหญิง
กับครูเอ๋
ไปก่อนนะคะเจอกันใหม่ค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ